okay not complicated right however
number one it is long and number two
like I said people get tripped up by
this subtraction here because you're
very you know half the time you're going
to get dominated his happening and we
easily mess up double daters so hands up
how many of you have encountered the
other before I love it ask if you can do
it now but if you've encountered
something to me ends up ok a very small
number that's fine there's a good reason
for that sin theta V is not in the
syllabus ok um and the reason why we
come parent as soon as I do it however
i'm going to show to you anyway because
it's so useful it counters those two
problems that i showed you yes
absolutely but i'm qualified in second
so I'm not hungry ok now um I want you
to have a look closely at your long
division ok i want you to notice that if
you wanted to do this again but with
different numbers ok a lot of what you
would do is very time consuming and very
repetitive ok for example have a look at
those armed havoc has powers of X powers
of it you know you're always going to
get the same thing on every column I
mean that's kind of a point of the
columns right you're all the X cubed
terms here all the X terms x squared
terms they're all the X terms and so on
you just have to write them but they're
always climbing down at how do you
notice that just like up here you climb
down from hundreds to tends to ones like
that's what you're supposed to do here
you're climbing down from excuse to X
squares 2 x's two constants ok so you're
always going to write the same thing
every time you're always going to end
with a cluster the second last one will
always be an X the third letter and so
on ok so being you're getting a same
predict to a pan the thing that really
matters is actually these numbers right
like 1 and negative 1 or 2 and negative
2 2 or 5 it's the coefficients that
really matter does that make sense so
therefore i can save myself a whole lot
of time by writing just the important
parts of the division namely the
coefficients ok so here's the way I'm
going to do I'm going to write a
Division sign but to
singlish what's going on I'm done about
it upside down okay it is a slightly
different business and I'm going to
write out the important part of my
dividend namely the coefficients which
are 1 1 negative 2 and fun do you see
those are the bits that matter okay yeah
the bits where I'm saying ah how many
times that fit to that multiply subtract
yes how do you know that no you're
dividing my so it's going to be in the
power play I'll get to that ok so so
what I got here is 1 1 negative 2 5 ok
now I will explain that when I explain
why this method is not in the syllabus
and why I'm going to teach you anywhere
ok all right now that's the first thing
that there is a time setting up
immediately you're going to get by not
having to write x cubed x squared X etc
ok the other thing that I pointed out
was it's hard because you've got all
these subtractions happening and soon as
you have a negative there you're
subtracting a negative so you get the
double negative and people mess it up ok
so in order to counter that all of these
subtractions happen from this number
right did you notice that you get this
goes over here that that's what makes
the minus x squared it's what makes the
minus 2x and so on right so if this
number were opposite in sign then I
wouldn't subtract her i would add it
right instead of subtracting negative 1
i would just add one right so instead of
getting negative 1 over here i'm just
going to write the opposite of that ok
another way of saying it is i'm taking
the zero of the divisor or the fruit of
the divisor right through this is one if
i were dividing by X minus 2 I just
write down too if I was divided by X
plus 1 I want it to be the opposite so I
don't have to subtract so i can add so i
would write negative 1 for this guy ok
in other words i'm trying to turn
subtraction into edition by just like
when we were doing addition and
subtraction of ordnance do you remember
that and I said hey tell me how to graph
sorry tell me how to graph this right
well I hate subtraction I'm trying to
avoid everywhere across so they can so I
reef a frame this subtraction as in
addition right so that's what I'm doing
instead of subtracting negative 1 i'm
going to be adding one all the way
through ok so now i'm pretty much ready
and be careful lick and you listen ok
that's how fast it um I've got
everything set up this is the equivalent
of having written all of this and
setting it all up and now i'm going to
show you the steps ok but first thing I
need to do is take this leading
coefficient that's what it really is
right the leading coefficient i'm just
going to write it down that's all I need
to do ok this is going to be this method
is going to focus on when I have
something like these when I'm / like X
minus 1 or X plus whatever ok just what
I've got a very simple divisor ok we
know how to divide other things that are
not so simple but I'll justify in a
second why I'm going to focus on these
guys ok I'm just going to write it down
because every time like if I had X to
the 4 here and still get execute it's
the fourth sorry execute up here it's
always going to be one if I had to say
2x cubed there and I / x i'm just going
to get to it's always going to be
divided by 1 so i just write this guy
down ok and here comes just like here
there was a step that I had to repeat
over and over and over again until I ran
out ok so here comes a step that repeats
until I'm on out i'm going to multiply
off that's what i did here i multiply it
down to there right so i multiply yet
one and then remember how i wrote the
opposite right so i did 1 x 1 and this
is the opposite of what i want to do so
instead of subtraction I've turned into
edition ok so what's one plus one
i'm going to multiply and they're not
going to add walls and then i'm going to
multiply and then I'm going to add I
told you if you blink you miss it okay
let me say it again right remember how
it's okay slow down I do another example
remember how what I was doing was I was
getting it on sir I was going to
multiply which gives me this and then i
subtract and then i multiply and then i
subtract and then i multiply in the
restaurant I've one out ok so here I've
done this in Reverse so that i can
multiply and add ok do you recognize
these numbers here to recognize them
because I've taken all the x's out I do
have to put the effort of putting the
excess back in ok now have a look what
we started with I started with degree 3
and I / 31 right so when you deal with
our index laws you know when you do to
agree 3/2 bring one you should end up
with degree two should end up with a
quadratic at some point so these
represent the coefficients of a
quadratic mainly x squared plus 2x plus
the constant I have a number ending up
on the end what's that guy that's the
remember that's what's left over ok